the challenges is growing up with a
brain injury and labeled the boy with a
broken brain I had to work so much
harder as everybody else I think that if
there's one skill to master in the 21st
century is the ability to learn rapidly
if you go around people tell people oh I
have a horrible memory I'm not smart
enough I'm getting too old fill in the
blank first of all if you fight for your
limitations you get to keep them need
motivation watch a top ten with believe
nation what's that belief nation at
seven my warn word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and join
today's lessons from a man who went from
being known as the boy with the broken
brain because of an injury he suffered
in his youth and struggling in school to
becoming a learning expert and helping
people unleash their super brains he's
Jim quick and here's my take on his top
ten rules of success enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one have a great work ethic my parents
immigrated here at the United States
from Asia we grew up like a lot of a lot
of individuals that work really hard
grew up in the back of a laundromat and
they had many different jobs and you
know I think one of the things that
that's important for all of us is just
the work ethic you know to be able to
put in like you do the incredible hours
as an entrepreneur as a visionary to do
whatever it takes because I don't
believe that there's a necessary magic
pill but I think there's a process and
doing the doing the work is very
important you know I don't want people
to believe that there's a silver bullet
all the sudden you have a great memory
or you have this great success or great
relationship or health and people always
ask what's the one thing I could do and
I always tell people that you have to do
you have to do most of it right and it'd
be smart about it but you have to put in
the work because you know a lot of times
people see on social media they see all
of the success but what they don't see
is the hustle and as this garyvee talks
about and the I think what you as they
say what you practice in private they
say you rewarded for in public but gee
up do you have to do the work and I
think that's where I got my work I think
the challenges is growing up with the
brain injury and labeled the boy with a
broken brain I had to work so much
harder as everybody else and you wonder
why that well you're not getting those
results and so um so I got my my
discipline from my for my parents and I
and I love them for me I really say that
they are my parent my superheroes
anything good that's come out of me is
really a product of them setting an
example
rule number two learn rapidly I think
that if there's one skill to master in
the 21st century is the ability to learn
rapidly it's if you know what it is they
call it in the military a force
multiplier
a force multiplier is like an input goes
in but you get exponential output from
it it's like optimism being positive is
it force multipliers right you know in
Qom palace of that and so certain things
like learning how to learn like metal
learning or improving your memory
proves everything improves your business
and proves like you know you could
remember people's names you can remember
sales presentations you could remember
things about uh people cuz like for
example it's hard to show somebody four
people are watching this they're
entrepreneurs right and they're wearing
business development hat you know it's
really hard to show someone you're gonna
care for their business their future
their family their health or fitness
whatever you're selling them if you
don't care enough just to remember
things like their name your name you
know or somewhere that or their or their
kids name or their birthdays you know so
that's a memories of Multiplier their
memories and multiplier in their
relationships
you know like relationships just
remembering those those moments you know
like you know not even just murmuring
anniversaries remember to take out the
garbage that kinda stuff but remembering
you know the first time you and your
loved one you know took that walk on
that Beach you know what I mean those
kind of moments that make everything
worthwhile yeah but it's it's wonderful
for every area Samarin yeah I do believe
that tomb of the most costly words and
business for example or I forgot you
know I forgot to do it I forgot to bring
it I forgot about me I forgot your name
it's been worse like did you get
forgetting someone's name and I've seen
this time and time again they could hurt
a relationship it could kill deals I've
had people call someone by the wrong
name and they've lost multiple million
dollar deals just on that rule number
three my personal favorite monitor your
self-talk but I always tell people is
this you have to monitor your self-talk
monitor your self-talk
if you go around people tell people oh I
have a horrible memory I'm not smart
enough I'm getting too old fill in the
blank first of all if you fight for your
limitations you get to keep them does
that make sense
a lot of people like oh I'm so forgetful
I'm so busy which that whole busyness
really bothers me like we're people so
you how are you doing I'm just so crazy
sub stress so busy it becomes like a
badge of honor that people will wear all
the time and then what do you start
reinforcing being busy right but to here
going back to this your self-talk is the
program that will run so you wanna be
mindful right and stand guard to your
mind because your mind is always
eavesdropping on your self-talk your
mind is always eavesdropping on your
self-talk rule number four transcend the
limitations my message to people whether
it's on state or in the podcast or
anything is that you know we are more
than what we're demonstrating that we've
been sold this lie
people are taught through school like
when I do these demos and I understand
stage memorize hundred names and words
and numbers forwards and backwards and
it appears effortlessly I always tell
people I don't do to impress you I do to
express to you what's really possible
because the truth is everyone can do is
too and so much more
apply towards creativity and focus and
flow and problem-solving and thinking
and and really overcoming the biggest
challenges of their life and maybe even
the world the challenges we were taught
a lot we were taught a lie that somehow
our intelligence our potential are
learning or memories somehow is fixed or
creativity is fixed we're thinking is
fixed like our shoe size and what we've
discovered you know as you know more
vehement about brain science in the past
two decades we discovered more than the
previous two thousand years and what we
know is that we're grossly under
estimating its capacity our own capacity
to be able to grow to be able to
contribute to improve our intelligence
and our influence and our impact and I'm
really I want to kind of pull the veil
behind and just say hey this is about
transcending you know this is about
ending the trance ending the trance that
you're that we're not good enough you
know that we're not smart enough that
we're not this genius and and telling
the truth and and the truth is people
can we're faster and we're smarter than
we think and not just to be able to rote
memorize things but be able to really
solve significant challenges and maybe
that these challenges that were going
through or the lessons that we need to
to learn the most and then some people
who learn those lessons feel compelled
to be able to share that voice with
other people so it's not just one candle
you know we just can set things ablaze
rule number five
start with why let's say someone has
horrible names right but let's say that
there's a suitcase a hundred thousand
dollars cash if you just remember the
name the next stranger you meet how many
people are gonna remember that person's
name well remember everyone right
and so that's the thing the M stands for
motivation
so it's interesting so all of a sudden
everyone's a memory expert but it had
nothing to do with their capacity or
their potential everyone could do it
it's just what they decided to do or not
if they wanted to it so it's almost like
if it's worth it enough where the
consequences are you know that big was
right or that big you're gonna miss out
on I'm not right the motivator exactly
because one of the things to learning we
know with human motivation because I did
this presentation and Bill Gates was
there he like and we're talking about
wealthy individuals right and so you
know he uh afterwards I talked to him I
was we're talking about the bridge
between education and technology and I
was like what's missing with the future
of learning and he was like Jim you know
the key is is human motivation really
understanding what drives people I was
like wow you know that's really right
because you know there's people who go
out there and they could buy courses you
know but a lot of never open it exactly
because it has everything to do with
Drive and reasons because motivation is
like you know like what is your motive
for acting sure right what's the fuel
and I believe there's success formula
caught h-cubed that goes from your head
to your heart to your hands the people
can visualize and affirm and see things
here all the time and think about it but
if they're not acting with their hands
you know actually doing something about
it then usually what's missing is the
second age which is the heart the
emotion the energy of motion and a
martial arts instructor tell me years
ago you can't steer a parked car
you know you need fuel you know where's
the energy that's gonna do that and so
with people's more traction so simple
when people are remembering people's
names ask yourself why do you want to
member this person's name because
reasons reap results I've always found
that in life reasons reap results cuz
you needed big enough why sure get out
light like Simon cynics book you know
start with why and so you want to get
that drive first rule number six change
your state you have so much intelligence
in your body right now I'll prove it to
jump up and down a little bit and make
little feet make a little space from the
person next to you if you can so if you
went like this you're ideally not gonna
take anyone's eye out or anything like
that okay no stop stop bouncing I love
the energy though notice where your feet
are
I want you keep your feet stationary the
entire time and what I want you to do is
with your right hand just point four
with your right hand your other right
hand sir sorry I know all right
forward with your right hand and what I
want you to do is out moving it without
moving your feet just turn to your right
clockwise as far as you could go and
notice where you're pointing as you take
your neighbors eye out notice how far
you go notice where you're pointing
those the exact spot come back Center
now put your arms down now I'm going to
take you through a really quick
visualization exercise so take a deep
breath exhale and close your eyes put
your arms by your side out of your
pockets by your side and breathe
normally and with your eyes closed or in
a play game I want you just to imagine
just imagine that you're raising your
arm again but this time imagine you're
turning twice as far two times as far
like you're getting good stretch it's
Pleasant feel that in your body and if
you can't imagine it just imagine that
you're imagining it and then again raise
your arm point forward and this time no
no with your eyes closed imagine just
imagine just imagine just in your mind
see and feel yourself turning three
times as far just feel it in your body
with your arms by your side just imagine
turning around three times and then one
more time with a smile on your face
thinking what does this have to do with
learning faster see and feel yourself
turning four times around in your body
see and feel yourself turning four times
around like you're Gumby like you're
made out of rubber great great stretch
all right open your eyes now
raise your arm again point forward with
your right hand now turn to your right
now as far as far as you can now go wow
raise your hand or make some noise if
you went further a second time have a
seat have a seat
now some of you went further some of you
went twenty-five percent further some of
you went fifty percent further yes raise
your hand if you ever went further a
second time now here's here's the magic
question right that you know I'm gonna
ask you even before I ask it were you
physically capable of turning that far
the first time
like nobody took a yoga class and my
eyes were closed right you're physically
capable of it
where was the block or the limitation if
there was one where was it in your minds
right in your mind and you're like Jim I
didn't have a belief on how far I could
turn
how many beliefs do you think we have
millions and zillions of beliefs right
because here's what you want to write
down all behavior is belief driven all
behavior is belief what some of you want
25 50 percent further with no anything
remember vision was talking about how
it's not just what's not working hard
but it's you one day when you're in a
certain state of mind you could just go
further and it's effortless
how many people aren't have experienced
this state of flow before that's data
flow where you lose track of time where
your attention is right there and you're
in the moment and it's the your level of
challenge is really matching your level
of capabilities and you're stretching
yourself and you're in that zone right
like that athletes talk about that
Steven Kotler talks about and the rise
of Superman and stealing fire and so on
how many people are familiar with
Steve's work by the way I'm just curious
as context okay so how do you get into
those states one of the ways is just
believing that you can because if you
believe you can or believe you can't
either way you're right because all
behavior is belief driven some of you
went 25 50 percent or more
what if you could go 25 50 percent more
in your business that effortless what if
you could go 25 50 percent even more in
your body or in your relationship did
you work harder the second time when you
turn the second time yes or no no
because it's a state right so behavior
so belief rule number seven have grit
we've talked about previously about
mindset and about had the importance of
having a growth mindset and I always
talk about the second gee from me as
grit and the 3 G's of the superhero
right yeah and I think so I think having
a powerful mindset being unstoppable or
just having the ability to go and and
succeed whatever success is for you you
have to you have to always you have to
be growing because we're not growing
then you're just your unit backs
right but you also need a level of grit
and I think rich just like growth is a
muscle it's something that you need to
sharpen through challenge because
through the challenging it though the
change that comes from it I would say
that if I'm if I'm affected having an
impact on stage and we all have a stage
of our life whether it's on a physical
stage or you know just going through our
day that I challenged my my grit and my
ability to persist I feel like that the
most successful people on the planet
that were dead to having the level of
impact that they want to have to go
through challenges rule number eight be
present let's say everyone uses a search
engine like Google every single day but
a lot of people they use it 10 times a
day if I ask them are you willing to bet
your life you know what colors the
letters are because that's that's an
observation you know there's a
difference between looking at something
and seeing it really seeing it there's
difference between hearing something and
really listening you know like leaders
like for example I had this whole
escapade with the x-men which was insane
but I had to leave the this set because
there I had to go to a charity event and
one of the people that I think the
leaders the independent of your
political bent who has an incredible
memory as President Clinton every single
time I've met President Clinton he's
remembered my name you know what he does
and how many people does he serve very
to them yes you how many people does
Kling meet on a regular basis right and
so that's a leadership skill though
right and so FDR was incredible with
names also he would walk around the
White House and point people out and say
hi to them say saying hi to their spouse
and using by name I mean that's cuz I
think about the sweetest sound of
person's ears right America's their name
all right and said so anyway I asked him
what's memory tricky uses he uses no
memory tricks at all and he tells me
this you know this is amazing don't
worry yes and so he tells me this
incredible story about how he knows his
grandfather you know in Arkansas but to
get all the kids around and tell stories
to them but then he would quiz them
they'd really need to listen to be
present and it's funny because I noticed
that like he's Bill Clinton is Anna
Carla sup already how you feel
politically incredible communicator
incredible charisma incredible connector
right and he also this memory I find you
know he's this incredible presence this
powerful presence but I find that his
powerful presence at his memory comes
from being powerfully present his
powerful presence comes from being
powerfully the presence and here's the
thing when people are networking because
I know a lot of people there's there
entrepreneurs or social entrepreneurs
and belittles and they're going out
there meeting people because really it's
it's what you know and it's who you know
but that's all memory what you know clap
people go to seminar two days later
they'll forget everything right 80
percent there's a big forgetting curve
but also who you know and who knows you
right but what its challenges is they'll
be networking and how many time do you
find yourself talking somebody and then
looking over their shoulder yeah you
want people to tell you that it's like
annoying because you're distracting
yourself at all times more if you're not
just dragging yourself externally you're
like talking to yourself what am I gonna
say Mary exactly so the people aren't
even listening that this is so key when
people are communicating most of the
times you find that they're not even
really listening what they are is
they're thinking about how they're gonna
respond yeah you know and if you look at
the word listen and you scramble the
letters it becomes the word silent no
yeah it's an expert what do people would
just do that rule number nine schedule
your reading time how do you read one
book a week leaders our readers the
challenges the average person reads
about two books a year but the average
CEO raised about four to six books a
month so how do you get to this point
where you're getting to one book a week
one of the reasons why I'm so excited
about reading is because if somebody has
decades of experience and they put it
into a book and you can sit down in a
day or two and read that book you can
download decades of knowledge in days
right so you have such a huge advantage
so how do you read one book a week
without speed reading well here's a
secret look at the numbers right when I
went onto Amazon it and out that the
medium number of words per book is about
64 thousand words
an average person like we teach speed
reading all around the world at 150
different countries online the average
person reads about 200 words per minute
so now when you divide 64,000 words per
book by 200 words a minute comes out to
be about 320 minutes
320 minutes to get through a book of
64,000 words but how many words is that
a day divided by seven you get about 45
minutes a day 45 minutes are reading a
day and you get through a one book a
week now that's much more manageable but
here's the secret is you have to
schedule it you must schedule this time
because if you say all I'm gonna read
here or there it never really happens
like it's more of a dream or it's an
interest but when you schedule it it's
in your appointment book it's in your
calendar this is time for you it's like
time you would have with your boss or an
investor or somebody a family member
something that's so important that you
would never cancel on that and rule
number 10 the last one before a very
special bonus clip is tap into your
greatness a few years ago now close with
this a few years ago I because I
remember someone Nate someone's name it
led to business that how many people
believe where Murray names is important
because if you forget someone's name
what's the communication you're sending
them that they're not what important how
are you gonna show somebody or care for
their business or future the finances
their health if you don't care enough to
remember them right and so I remember
someone's name it lets his business for
20th Century Fox and was for the
chairman and I was training him and his
executive team out of Friday and I go
there and because I was in state because
I saw this avatar like like memorabilia
and I saw this movie poster with Star
Wars I was like a kid right so I gave my
best training ever and afterwards they
really felt it he was like gave me a
tour of the whole place and everything
and I saw this movie poster of Wolverine
I know this for me is a big deal but
moving coming out I was like wow I can't
afford a film to come out and he picks
up the chairman picks up the phone and
five minutes later I'm in the Fox
Studios with 3d glasses watching Hugh
Jackman fight all these super ninjas
right and I'm in my bliss on a Friday
afterwards he comes to me he says Jim
how was the movie I was like spray thank
you so much I tell my story how I grew
up with learning disabilities I taught
myself how to read by reading comic
books my favorite comic book
or the x-men Wolverine and the x-men and
not because there is strongest is
because they didn't fit in because I
felt like I didn't fit in growing up as
a kid does that make sense with his
disability and the boy with the broken
brain and the highlight of the comic
books for me was when I read that the
school for the gifted for the
superheroes was in for x-men was in
Westchester New York and that as the
suburb of New York City and that's where
I grew up so when I was nine years old I
used to ride my bicycle all around the
neighborhood trying to find this school
because I wanted I wanted to run away I
wanted to find my superpower something
that I was good at and I want to find my
super friends because when you're the
boy with the broken brain you don't you
don't connect with a lot of people
because you don't feel like you have a
lot to offer right so I used to do that
I'm telling you this story the Chairman
is like Jim I don't like superheroes you
want to go to comic-con now what if you
were familiar with comic-con right tens
of thousands people getting together San
Diego dressed up like like you know
superheroes I was like when is it it's
like a Friday sorry Sunday now notice my
mind I go from a nine year old to a 99
year old because I'm like I'm in LA I'm
gonna get to San Diego on a Friday right
there's me lines every traffic I have
nothing to wear up all these meetings in
LA and noticed like the critic that
comes in right because sometimes we have
to get out of our own way and it
mentally I just became an old person in
my mind and then I was like it's like
Jim do you want to go I'm going tomorrow
and he was like oh I was like oh you're
going tomorrow I wanna go with you
so he picked me up Saturday morning and
we instead of driving down there we get
on his plane and I swear to you on that
planes the entire cast of x-men and
they're gonna surprise comic-con right
with their presence for the new movie
that's coming out and I spent the entire
like I go on there and I'm kinda I see
Wolverine and and Patrick's like you
know Professor X I've seen between
Jennifer Lawrence and Halle Berry going
to comic-con right and we spend the
entire day amazing we come back here's
here's here's the lesson we come back
and chairman Lee like how was it I was
like the best day ever thank you so much
he was like he's like you know my
something else for you I like I don't
want anything else what can I do for you
he was like they really loved you how
would you like to go to Montreal they
were filming the last 30 days in the new
movie I'm like oh wow I've never been on
films I would love to do it but what can
I do for you he says Jim just do what
you did with us just chair teach him how
to speed read scripts memorize their
lines faster
present and focus on set and I was like
I could totally do that
Sunday morning we're on but they called
the x-jet and we're going to Montreal
and I'm brain training these amazing
individuals that inspired me like
growing up right and I got to see like
on set it was actually taking place at
the school and I got to see my real-life
heroes come to life in front of me as a
nine-year-old boy now when I got home
there was a package waiting for me I
open up I don't if you could put this
the last two slide on please I open it
up and there's this photograph on the
screen there's a photograph of me and
the entire cast of x-men and even better
than Halle Berry and Jennifer Luntz
everything that's on there was the note
from the Chairman it said this Jim thank
you so much for sharing your superpowers
with all of us I know you've been
looking for your superhero school since
your kid here's your class photo
[Applause]
the third the lesson that it that
everyone gets different lessons out of
this for me is is me being in that
childhood vulnerable state that allowed
something like that to happen and the
what I would leave for you is this
homework if you is it okay if I give you
some homework is this movie was called
Days of Future past it takes place in
the future and it's there's Armageddon I
mean it's the most dreaded future you
could ever imagine and Professor X sends
Wolverine because Wolverine has healing
abilities with his mind sends him back
in time as like the communicator to talk
to his younger self so professor X sends
Wolverine back in time to talk to the
younger version of Professor X to tell
him something so that way the future
gets changed does that make sense so my
question for you is this if you could go
back to that child inside of you that
younger self and right now tell them
something that they need to hear what
would that be if you could go back and
pass on a message to your younger self
what would it be and if you were to go
in the future one year two years five
years ten years and in the future I
believe you have wisdom inside of you I
believe you have greatness inside of you
and genius that you not even even tapped
in those states if you were to project
ten years ahead of time and look back on
this day right now what is your current
self need to hear from your future self
I have a quote that I get quote on more
than anything else it talks about an egg
and stress that your egg is like your
life that if an egg is broken by an
outside force life ends but if it's
broken by an inside force life begins
and all great things begin on the inside
thank you very much
now I've got a really special gym quick
bonus clip on how to practice self-care
that I think you're really gonna enjoy
but before that I want to know which
rule resonated more with you monitor
your self-talk or start with why which
one did you like better leave in the
comments below thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clip I always tell people that
self love and self care is not selfish a
lot of people you know they're there for
their friends and their family and their
clients everybody else but they're not
refilling their their cup so I think
that we have to be you know grow givers
I mean we have to we crose way more to
give to other people so we have more
impact with other individuals so the
behaviors are reading each day and
putting together your to-do list and
you're I think having your not to-do
list is so important having being
sleep-deprived for so many years you
know I think a lot of people I'm super
sensitized to it but I think one of the
success rituals people has should have
is just going through and keeping a
consistent not to-do list and I think
the most successful genius-level
individuals one of the clues that they
leave is there not to-do list is bigger
than their to-do list right they don't
check their phone in the morning they
don't take him you know everything is
hell yes or it's hell no all right
that's their filter system they don't
and you know they say no to good so
there's two great new if you tell
yourself a story long enough you start
to believe it don't you believe you act
like I am Tulsa what a wail out of a
handcuffed lightning both Thunder in
jail now you know I'm bad over the last
week I murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between 18 and
250 four days of taking action for a new
habit to stick I've created a new course
called 250 for confidence or every
single day for 250 four days I will be
sending you a video between 30 seconds
and 5 minutes long that you start your
morning with around making you feel
confident it's absolutely free check out
the link in the description below to get
access